take two CEO Strauss zelnick speaks out
about the GTA 6 leaks and how it has
affected Rockstar in an interview with
IGN following the parent company's
latest earnings call zelnik described
the leak as quote really upsetting and
frustrating to the team but has not
affected the company or the game from a
business perspective the GTA 6 leak
dates back to September 2022 when
extended gameplay videos and screenshots
from the game appeared online in
addition to reportedly confirming the
game's rumored Vice City setting and
Bonnie and Clyde inspired story The Leak
reveals that the game could feature sex
robots and alligators within days of the
league coming to light the supposed
perpetrator appeared in court and was
held in the Youth Detention Center
during the same interview zelnick spoke
to the implementation of AI in video
games while zelnik believes the new AI
tools could help with development he is
skeptical of its ability to develop a
game without human Developers the
executive went on to say that the
popular AI tool chat GPT is similar to a
hand calculator decades ago parents
worried that hand calculators would mean
children wouldn't need to learn math but
that wasn't the case quote the answer is
yes you still have to learn math turns
out you absolutely have to learn math
but you have a tool that makes it easier
to do and chat gbt is the same thing he
said looking at the wider gaming
industry Battlefield publisher
Electronic Arts is working on AI
technology and has been for years in
2018 E8 announced project Atlas an r d
project with 1 000 people working on it
that aims to change how games are made
through Ai and neural networks this
technology was implemented into the
battlefield series and it was smart
enough to play the game and even play
The Objective which is more than can be
said for a lot of players a game that
some people might believe to be the
product of AI is the day before I highly
anticipated survival zombie game that
has once again opened itself up to
controversy the game's developer
fantastic has previously been criticized
for its claims the game is being built
by over 100 quote volunteers and tested
by dozens of unpaid supporters the title
was meant to release in March of this
year before being pushed to November
which the developer initially stated was
due to a copyright claim before late
revealing that the delay was planned
before the issue around Rights was even
raised the copyright claim did however
delay a 10 minute Gameplay trailer that
the developer claimed needed to be
approved by lawyers before posting I
wonder if their legal team are
volunteers as well the Gameplay trailer
has since released but an eagle-eyed
YouTuber Force gaming discovered
something particularly fishy about the
video in that it seems to recreate
several shots from a trailer for Call of
Duty Black Ops cold wars zombie mode now
while it's important to give devs the
benefit of the doubt as someone that's
been in digital media nearly 10 years
there seems to be a pretty clear copy of
the Call of Duty trailer the angle of
the shots the placement of the
characters let's just say if this was a
paper you handed into a college
professor and they ran it through a
plagiarism program they'd be asking you
to meet them in their office it would be
one thing if this trailer was
intentionally designed as an homage to
these other games but as that hasn't
been made clear plus when you bundle
this with the games last minute delays
removal from Steam the volunteer
Workforce the trademark dispute and
other complications it throws the entire
project into question even further as
recording developer fantastic has not
commented on the accusations what are
your takeaways from everything you've
seen with the day before so far let us
know in the comments we'll see you here
for more on Gamespot news